[Music]
welcome everybody to this workshop on
building
user uh building user adaptive
interfaces with media preferences i'm
adam argyle
i'm super stoked to walk you through
this today it's marked as a beginner
uh workflow today or like a beginner
task but
let's just say the beginner aspects of
this is that you'll be going for a ride
and i'm going to take you on this ride
you're going to copy and paste
code and see it will react and the page
sort of update
with your changes but just know that
this
is jam packed with various uh things to
learn about today about css and just
building on the web we are entering a
new type of web
where things don't just change to the
screen size they changed to
my operating system and the preferences
that i've made on that and
and the way that those flow into our
page can get us into this new era
of user adaptive interfaces and so we're
gonna
you know program our entire uh all of
our code today is
in this premonition that we want to be
uh building for
user adaptivity we want the choices of
our users to be reflected inside of here
so
okay like that's what we're doing here's
kind of what we're building i like dark
themes so that's why we have a dark mode
user settings page down here and if i go
into like a mobile view you can see it
go into a mobile view
right okay so nothing too surprising
here this is basically kind of like
responsive design
but what we're going to get into is sort
of these these really small details and
decisions that we're going to make from
the ground up that put the user first
and so let's talk a little bit about
like user preferences
like your device that you chose was a as
a choice it's an option for you whether
you were on mobile or desktop these are
things that you bring to the table
it also comes down to like what language
do you have set on your device what
language do you and direction do you
like to read
and these are all things that should
play all the way into your page you're
here to just
consume some content right like we're in
this era now where the page can
bend to me instead of me bend to the
page and let's look at like
some more of those things that we can do
here so we have like device
viewport we talked about that before
this like we have 10 years of like
device
viewport re reactivity in our layouts
and stuff
uh you know device orientation so we're
rotating it font size has been something
that's been around for a while but it's
often overlooked where the user
it could they can choose a font size in
their browser and you have a choice as
an author to
collaborate and and not use it or to
build upon it and sort of
work up from it and so that's what i
mean we're going to be using relative
units today
and for one thing is font size we're
going to be making sure that that user's
font size is respected in our
application
online on offline network connectivity
color scheme you know this one's really
popular right now light and dark
users land on the page and they don't
know what theme it was originally built
in and it's not the brand theme it's
now adapting to me as the user we have
interface animations that can know
whether or not you like uh motion or not
right we have that
option in our interface let's use that
in our pages we have input like
are they on a keyboard how are they even
interfacing with this page are they on a
nintendo switch
if they're on a switch they don't have a
mouse so
how are they going to fill out and use
your experience we all want to make sure
that we are listening to that
we have document dimension uh direction
and writing modes we have the display
mode
so whether or not they're even launching
in a browser or from an app experience
and then things coming down the piper we
have like reduced
data so are they browsing in a reduced
like data saver state
we can change the page we can change the
page based on how many colors their
device can display so if someone's
visiting from a
older device we don't want to you know
show crazy colors there we want to show
just
um the ones that it can display there's
like where web safe was there and now we
have
colors that go really vibrant these days
and these really dynamic screens and so
a user is bringing capabilities like a
device capability to the table and we
want to make sure that
the user doesn't have to think about
that and our application is just showing
itself in the best light that it can
and those are just a few of the things
that we can look at today and
a few of the things that we can look
forward to in the future
so we have media queries uh that's a
little breakdown if you don't know what
those are you can check it out there
user adaptive
is what we're talking about now is this
concept where a user is visiting our
page and we are adapting to them
and we're going to do that in a lot of
ways so what we're going to build
is we're going to build this form where
it's going to look like this in the
beginning
it's just an html document and we'll go
over that in just a second
and we're gonna transform it into
something that's responsive uh is liquid
and has all these nice animations in it
so that you can
build a settings page or build a form i
feel like most most experiences in the
world
eventually push you into a form at which
point hopefully that form is easy to use
because that's sort of the money-making
moment where
someone either creates content or buy
something or they don't
so we gotta make sure our forms are uh
good and work well
out of the box so by the end what we're
going to have is a light and a dark
theme
just with some css custom properties
we're going to have animations
and accessibility so we're going to make
sure that this thing can be keyboard
interacted mouse interacted
and that the motion and the colors are
all accessible
it's really cool stuff we're going to
work on we're going to make sure it is
layout is adaptive and we're going to do
this without media queries
we have one media query that checks to
see the device orientation
but otherwise we try to do this very
intrinsically and this is sort of an
advanced layout topic is intrinsic
layout but we're going to be
implementing one of those today so that
it's responsive without a media query
just sort of
folds into the space if it can or not
you know so it's sort of
you're agnostic to the device anyway and
then we're also going to use
relative units and logical properties
relative units are units that we can use
to respect a user's preference and build
up from there and logical properties are
a way for us to not care about the
direction of the document whether
someone's reading right to left top to
bottom bottom
top we just we just want to be agnostic
to that i just want to lay it out with
how it looks for me now
logical properties let us do that where
we can uh
to find the space with the way that it
looks in my language and my computer
right now
but anyone opening it up in a different
language in a different writing mode
different direction
they'll see it natively and naturally in
theirs with all the spacing appropriate
and it's just really cool so
uh what you'll need is just a browser
doesn't necessarily have to be chrome
and let's dive into the next section
here
this is getting all set up so uh there's
a few ways to do this you can go to
github
so i have the repository here you can
find a link in the
codelab i recommend though using codepen
so if you just follow the codepen link
and click the fork button right down
here at the bottom right
that will um just take make a copy of
this entire project and you'll get css
live reloading html live reloading all
that stuff for free
you only need an account on codepen if
you want to save it so if today you just
want to kind of follow along in the
workshop
don't even make an account just fork
that uh codepen
and start working along with me and
everything will be fine if you want to
though you can work locally download the
code
i used veet as a build system and it's
nice and fast and very minimal
shouldn't put a whole lot of files on
your computer uh and yeah that's
a couple of ways to get started there i
want to talk briefly about the html and
we'll get into that because this
is not an html lesson this wants to
focus on css so i had to kind of
not do some things with y'all in the
workshop and one of them was write this
html so i'm
providing what i feel is a reasonably
semantic
document form that tries to include as
much as it can without any styles
and we'll briefly go over some of that
stuff but that's about the html and
about kind of getting set up
and hopefully you have had enough time
now to open up the
uh codepen hit that fork button and
you're just ready to go you're ready for
like what's next
so let's check it out our next step here
is adaptive interactions
all right so our form our document
needs to be interactive now css can kind
of facilitate some of these things but
html gives us a lot of these for free
and by the end of this we're going to
make sure that we have a form that is
gamepad and keyboard ready
uh mouse and touch ready and screen
reader or similar assistive technology
ready
and we're going to do that by so i'm
going to kind of skip over some of the
writing in here in the code lab
in favor of filling in some of the gaps
um
like there this is a very uh advanced
and beginner type of lesson so i'm going
to try to like i packed a lot into the
writing
and i'm going to try to fill in some
gaps audibly here like one of the things
is
this works across all modern browsers
and we'll get into sort of when those
moments are that you're sort of
pushing out an older browser like ie
because we're going to do a lot of our
color manipulation
in css calc with hsl and that just that
syntax doesn't work good with old
ies so anyway i'll try to cover some of
those things as well but there will be a
push and a pull between the document and
our coding here
okay so for first one we have grouping
uh inputs and so you can see that we
have settings here
is in this kind of weird box and
notifications are in this weird box
and those are grouped and that's we're
grouping those with the field set that's
an element for sort of grouping like
typed inputs
and i've already got that set up for you
so you don't have to do anything there
but by using things like
inputs and h2s and these sort of other
semantic html elements we're able to get
keyboard navigation
for free we can tab between these but we
did have to go modify it a little bit
so there's a little gif there that shows
the experience beforehand
and after i like to add this css style
here of outline offset
5 pixels and and that's just to give
this a little bit output a little bit of
offset so here i'm going to copy that
and just paste it right down at the
bottom
our css so this is our first little copy
paste and now if i tab through
you can see that there's a little bit
more space around our elements it's not
quite so
shrink wrapped so there's things to try
here now that that's there is you can
try connecting a gamepad and
moving through this you can try using
your keyboard so i'm just hitting tab
if you know how to use a screen reader
go ahead and try to use the screen
reader and just see what the basic
experiences that we're trying to build
upon here
okay let's talk about a mouse so a mouse
can even be getting
like more affordances in a form through
just
a couple of proper html attributes now
i've already wrote written them in the
html for you
but the way that they work is like right
now if you look at the layout even with
no styles
it's hard to know which title and and
description
is with which checkbox but since we did
some proper labeling here and i'll
scroll down here and we said that the
input was four and the label was for a
certain input
input we're able to hover over our label
here
and that will highlight the appropriate
checkbox so i don't know if you can see
that down here but as i like
highlight and you can see this in your
demo too is if you highlight the right
label and stuff you'll see the
appropriate and associated checkbox
um kind of you know toggle a little bit
in its style and i think that's really
important for users to know which one
visually right with a mouse like which
checkbox is associated with which label
and you can create that connection there
just in the html and then you also get
the affordance of you can click the
label itself to toggle the checkbox so
you sort of like increase its hit area
you create this connection so that the
label and the checkbox are tied together
it's just a whole bunch of wins and you
get it right there in the html
um some things that note about a screen
reader so screen reader is essentially
someone's coming here and they can't see
well we have icons which really are only
good for people who can see
so one of the things that we do in the
html here is we put arya hidden
equals true on those so i'm putting an
icon inside of a picture element and by
putting arya hidden on those pictures
we now no longer tab through
the icon and the label and this item
here we can sort of say
hey this is visually hidden i want this
to be available for mouse users but
screen reader users they don't need to
stop on this icon
it's just not going to do them any value
right it's just sort of
an unnecessary stop along the way so for
user experience purposes we can just
sort of say
it's hidden from you and now as they tab
through and they're working through our
document
with that site they'll uh skip over the
things that were made for
sighted users so kind of just cool
little things that we're doing in here
for this
user adaptive form users are coming here
they bring
their own tools to the table and we want
to make sure that we're handling all
those as good as we can
so our html has set us up really well
for that which is using input sliders
some check boxes and a couple of these
little attributes
on our elements to connect them to the
rest of the thing so let's move on to
our next section into the kind of
exciting section the first one which is
adaptive layouts
and by the end of this we're going to
have a spacing system we're going to
have
flexible and responsive alignment and
spacing and we're going to have a
responsive layout
we're going to use logical properties
and i'll talk briefly about those
and we're going to write a media query
or two just to sort of like finesse
those edges okay so for spacing
uh let's jump into our first copy and
paste task here which is this root
copy paste so we're gonna copy and paste
all of that and
i'm gonna put this at the top of my
style sheet but honestly you can throw
it right at the bottom if you want it's
not that big a deal
and you should see no change because all
we've done is defined some
custom properties um that create a
spacing system it's like a pseudo system
and you can see it's just like a quarter
ram here so we're using that rem unit
the rem
unit i do have some links uh look it
looks it's right here
mindful of a user's preference if you're
curious how the rem is mindful of a
user's preference
follow that link and study it and you'll
see what we mean
and so by using a quarter ram here
that's our smallest unit half rem
is our extra small small and i kind of
liked this naming
because that way a designer or someone
could come up and be like uh that's
spacing between those two elements can
you make that
extra large and then you can be like
well yeah that's exactly what my custom
property is named how did you know
uh maybe that maybe that would happen to
you i don't know i hope
it does it'd be really fun anyway okay
so all we did is paste some variables we
haven't used them
and so they're pretty much null at this
point they're not doing any any value
so let's add our first set of page
styles now these styles here are kind of
what some people might call a reset
um and that's not necessarily far off
but it's not a full reset
and you can see essentially what it did
is it took all the space out of all our
elements and that's because right here
we're selecting every element we're
setting its margin to zero and it's box
sizing to border box
that might not work for your app but
it's going to be how we start this one
we're going to be using a lot more gap
in our layout today
and so we're going to start by zeroing
out margins because we're going to have
container owned spacing whereas margin
is a child owned space
we set the document to 100 height so
block size is a logical property for
the vertical well it's like the way that
your paragraphs stack and in this case
it's the height of our document
block size is a height in latin um
anyway and in line size would be width
and we'll see that here in a second
so then the body is set to min of the
block size so essentially we're saying
like hey html document fit the viewport
and the body should fit that
html document did you know that there's
two uh nodes between you and your other
elements anyway
so that's what that's doing then we have
some padding here we have padding block
start and padding block end and they're
each using one of our custom properties
so we're using
some light spacing on the top and bottom
of our body
um block start and block end uh we'll go
over some more logical properties in a
second okay so that's essentially what
that paste did it was just sort of like
giving us this baseline
shrinking all of our elements and
putting some padding on the bottom body
let's do some light typography as well
so i'm going to take this
set of styles here and paste them
underneath the body selector here
if you want you can consolidate these
like take the font family here and put
it up into the previous one
it's not required um for today what i
want you to really be focused on is
what user centric choices am i making in
this code snippet
so when we paste it what was our intent
and i'm hoping that
that's the primary thing you take away
from today is a lot of these things are
rooted in our user we're thinking about
our users so often
okay so here's one font family system ui
this uh font family will come from
whatever system they've chosen
so if they're on their favorite linux
machine they're gonna get a linux font
that looks exactly like their other
system apps
if they're on mac os they're gonna get
the beautiful san francisco font and
it's gonna look like all their other
apps
essentially you make them not think
they're going to be reading content as
legibly as they've been reading it all
day because you didn't change it on them
you gave them just a sans-serif system
ui
there's even way more cool powers that
come with system ui but we won't get
into those
i set a couple of font weights here on
those headers i don't change their size
so we're just going to use the native
font size
and i set this small to have a line
height of 1.5 and that's this guy here
um and that's because by default it was
just so shrunk and it's just too tight
on the content so
anyway that's what those are for let's
talk
briefly about logical properties okay so
logical properties i mentioned is an
agnostic way for you to talk about
um a web layout or a box really it's
about a box as a box
uh needs to have content in it right we
always talk about css is all about boxes
and when we talk about logical
properties we want to talk about a box
that's not necessarily about ourselves
so i like to think about it if you
ask someone and you want to shake their
hand you could ask for their right hand
which would be a physical reference
or you could ask for their strong hand
logical properties
are like asking for a user's strong hand
and not assuming that they have a right
hand
which is really important when you need
to do layout that can go top to bottom
right to left or top to bottom and right
to left you have to think about these
boxes in a way of
flow as opposed to appearance so instead
of saying it's the left side of a box
we'd say it's in english or latin it'd
be the inline start of a box so it can
be kind of
initially confusing because no one talks
about boxes this way but
over time what we're going to have done
is aligned everyone in the entire world
on how to talk about boxes because we
have a way to talk about boxes that
isn't about
us it's about the box so i strongly
recommend getting into these
they um are a small change to this the
syntax that you write but the
output is drastically different you're
making a much more accessible and
international document
uh with your spacing using custom or
logical properties
so there's also other things about this
uh that you've probably already been
getting trained on like you might know
what flex start and flex
end is or like flex direction row and
column these have all been training you
with logical properties you just didn't
really know it and so um that flex start
is the same thing as inline start this
is
think about like the way where your
writing starts if you were to write by
hand
that's your writing on the inline
direction in english and then your
paragraphs
stack on top of each other anyway so you
have blocks of paragraphs
and you have inline you write in line so
if you think about it anyway that helps
me think about it maybe it'll help you
let's get into some css uh today our
layouts are all done with grid
so uh i love flexbox i think it has tons
of merit and but it just didn't end up
being in this layout
and there's no particular reason i think
it's actually just that i needed
more um sized boxes like i had icons and
stuff i'm like i'll just make a column
at this size and stick an icon in there
anyway um grid and flexbox are both
great at micro
and macro layouts but today grid is
going to do all of them
and then here's a screenshot that shows
um all the dev tools overlaid at once so
here let's check that out that's just
fun so if i hit command shift c
i'll open up the dev tools and we can
see over here on the right
i've got sort of grid tools and i can
toggle these on and toggle all of them
on and start to see
all the spacing that shows up in between
all my elements here
so if you haven't used the grid dev
tools they're really nice for that
and that's how you interact with them
you sort of go into your elements panel
and turn them on you can also go over
here to the layout panel
and toggle them from here but they're
all on the list you just turn these on
um really cool so i'm going to pop the
tools out there
i'm also just while we had that open
i'm going to open up the dev tools again
i'm going to hit command shift p and i'm
going to go to light
theme and i can emulate css prefers
color light here and just sort of show
the light theme i can also do that down
here in the rendering panel
and i can toggle light and dark from
here so we'll be going over some of
these things later once we do more color
but i just kind of wanted to show
um that right now while i had the dev
tools open
all right i'm going to close that out
just to cancel out some of the emulation
and go back into our layout so i'm
actually going to pull
up the css here so that i'm looking more
at the styles
because we're about to paste a lot more
code so here's the layout for our main
element
and our main element is the primary
element around the entire layout
so let's paste that at the bottom
all right so display grid so what did we
get right off the bat here we said
display grid with a gap
of large gap we put the content in the
center and we put a little bit of
padding on there the padding is so that
when we shrink down we get some of the
padding
and then the spacing here is really only
between this header and these content
items here
so grid by default creates rows we put
some space between the elements in there
and we centered it all
okay let's check out what's our next one
our form our form has our coolest layout
uh also the most complex layout here's
the most algorithmic
of all the layouts um and the most
intrinsic and the one worth talking
about the most
and the one that i've said and the most
times with right okay
so but if you notice we now have a
responsive layout
without a media query and how does this
layout know to kind of fold
up or fold down these additional content
boxes
well let's talk about that so max width
is the first sort of quirky uh aspect of
this layout and what
this form needs to do with max width is
say how big
it can grow to it's not normal for
css and layout for you to do that but
with this grid layout we did need to do
that and the reason is we're using this
repeat autofit min max
algorithm and it needs to know the
absolute largest
that it can grow to and 100 percent is
just not a value
like not a good value for it it doesn't
understand 100
when something is shifting like this 100
could mean
just the width at the one vertical and
so you had to be explicit with max width
we also have two different gaps here we
have a row and a column gap and that's
so that
this gap here in between these two
sections is different
than this gap here this gap here is
larger
than this one and in one little
definition here we can say the row and
the column spacing and so when this
thing is folding on itself
it has a different amount of space when
it's going here and it does here
it's just super cool grid is so rad we
align the items to flex start and that's
so that they don't get stretched
we can see that here see how the bottom
edge of these isn't the same
if we didn't have stretch there those
would be the same and then let's get
into this algorithm okay so we're saying
for each child so this form has two
field set sections
uh that we want to be responsive and
we're going to say repeat autofit min
max
so we want to autofit these elements at
a minimum and a maximum of we'll say a
maximum of 35
characters and we can see here that
that's essentially this size that they
are
they're saying i don't grow beyond 35
characters that's my max and that's what
gives this next column the availability
to autofit is it's there's maximum there
and then the minimum is so that we can
shrink super squishy
and i know that sounds kind of funky but
like min max has this
issue where sometimes if you set min to
10 characters you wouldn't get a hundred
percent flexibility at certain
small viewports and anyway there's
articles written about what this
is doing exactly and why it's so tricky
why does min max with a min function
included here with like 10 characters
100 and it's just this little
algorithmic edge case where when you're
getting into a small viewport you want
100
and not 10 characters and that's
essentially what we're doing we're
saying take the minimum it's either 10
characters or 100 and in this case
that's 100 we want that to fill
that space so anyway that was our
trickiest layout
and i'm going to move on to our section
so here's our section
paste this down here look at our html so
it went form and section so
each uh the form element that we just
gave that responsive layout is actually
having a responsive set of sections oh
right there's sections not field sets
because the field set is the border
and the section has a header and a field
set right
so cool this uh section
uh layout gave us gap between our header
here and here and here we can just kind
of show that here
pop open our dev tools get into our
section grid and so here's that section
grid we just made
here's that form grid that we made we
can see as we respond here the
difference in
um like gap that we see in the middle
there versus the horizontal gap
and that's because that one definition
that we did we can get up in here to the
main
and see how it's responding and then we
can just see all three of these all
together really quick just to see
what are they doing and why did we need
so many layouts
and you can see that just putting space
between items often means you need
another container and you need items to
be wrapped in something
so that's where a lot of that came from
i'm gonna close out of dev tools get
back into
here and check out our next layout which
is on the field set
so i'm gonna grab this field set pop
down here and paste it
we can see that we dropped our padding
around the edge here we went to a
display grid which was kind of similar
to what it was before
but then we're gonna get some ability to
put a gap in there notice our gap is one
pixel
and that's really interesting here if
you can see the one that like hairline
between each of these that's actually
you looking through
a gap into the background of the field
set so normally you might use like a
border bottom and then say if it's not
the last item don't have a border bottom
because otherwise you'd see like a
double border down here
but with gap i'm i'm actually using gap
as the hairline
and i thought that that was just like
that's how designers think at least
that's how the surface feels
um or it looks like it should feel like
the item should be able to swipe on us
anyway whatever this might just be me
thinking about it too hard but i had a
lot of fun
making a hairline design choice with css
grid gap i
thought that was really nice we have our
border radius which is using some of our
custom properties for spacing so notice
our spacing is just sort of like medium
and small and large and medium
and then we're staying really consistent
by using our custom properties and it's
going to be one of the key things that
has our layout looking so harmonious
is that we used a limited palette of
these
spacing items so anyway we also said
overflow hidden because we set a border
radius and we're about to set a color
background on that later
and we're going to want that color to be
contained in that border radius
okay let's check out field set item and
make sure i grab all of that field set
item
this is the only class or one of the few
class names that we wrote
and a field set item is for each of
these items that sort of has an icon and
has a slider and all these items inside
of it
we set a display to grid here and look
our grid template columns our first
column is spacing large and that's
actually
creating a column here for the icons and
then the rest of the item is this one fr
so sort of a flexible amount of space
and then a fixed
size for the icon which i think just
makes a lot of sense right you're like
here's
the space for the icon center that icon
in the space and then
give the fluid space to the rest of the
content there we add a gap using our
spacing we add some pacing
or padding using our spacing nothing too
confusing there i thought that was
really nice let's look at our field set
item picture
these are for each of our icons and
we're setting the block size and the
inline size this is again like height
and width except that it's agnostic to
height and width it will always be
appropriate to the writing mode and
we're using our space xl
so we're taking that icon we're giving
it a very clear height and width
we're giving it a clip path of a circle
at 50 which we'll see later
it prints a circle it will clip the
element into a circle almost like border
radius
um but i like the syntax a little bit
better plus we're going to animate it
we use display inline grid and we place
the content into the center
great let's check out field set item and
we have a cool selector in here using
the is
sudo selector the functional pseudo
selector here is
has great support these days and here if
i pull this out you should be able to
see the full selector
excellent so we're saying field set item
if you have a direct descendant that is
a picture or a direct ascendant channel
that is an input type check box
place them into the center and we see
that here
so this item is placing itself into the
center and these icons are placing
themselves into the center they're sort
of like
claiming center ownership on their own
and that's what self
is good for because not everything well
that's why it's the direct descendant
you can go look at the
code not everything is always a direct
descendant and needs to be centered and
so
this way we target just those two
elements that need that
that nudge let's look at our field set
item svg so i'll grab this
i'll paste it under here so these are
going to be the actual like
icon math values that are being used to
draw the actual icon so we've created
we created a column then we created a
firm box and now we're going to size
we created the box so that we could put
a circle around it and put some shape
around it like here let's preview over
here
right so yeah we have this circle around
here and as i interact with it it grew
that's that clip path and that's that
outer box that we're working on right
now
but now we're gonna work on the svg
inside and we're going to set its block
size to var space medium so essentially
we're setting the
actual icon size right here and the
other things we're creating a box
that had space around it so that the
icon could be in a circle
and that's just uh yeah this is we're
just burning right through it okay so
now we have
small stack and the reason this is small
stack is this was just like a little
utility class that created a grid and
added gap
and i often call this grid um just for
gap like sometimes i use grid
i'll set display to grid just to use a
gap gap is that good and here's a kind
of good example of it so small stack
went on top of
numerous elements in here and it's
basically just to add an extra small
amount of gap
between items you can go check the html
to see where that was but if i delete it
here
you can see that yeah it was mostly up
in here um oh we're taking the label
and the sliders and the labels and these
content here we're putting space between
them and we're setting them into a block
direction so we can see that those
stacked again
all right let's look at input type
checkbox
and it's getting a height and width and
see this is i thought this was nice
because
checkboxes are awfully small even for
enabled user with a mouse and you can
change the size of them
so i've essentially changed the height
and width of them right here and make
them much more clickable
and they render really nice so i don't
see any reason why we shouldn't always
increase the size of our checkboxes to
be
easier to use like that okay at this
point we've already done this a little
bit we'll just like open up dev tools
and look at your various layouts like
look at what we have so far
okay and all we've done is uh created
some css custom properties for spacing
and then a bunch of layout work where we
we took the html and we started
putting the elements in the right spot
and putting space between them and look
how far
padding and proper gaps will get you
um that's the majority of the work at
least in this case
and we've just taken this document this
document will now work in all these
other different languages
and writing modes because we're using
logical properties and and grid
which will automatically do the sort of
directionality work for us at the end of
the
day
so again we're taking this like document
that wasn't very good at adapting to
users
and we're layering in all these
different choices to make it more and
more adaptive to more
different use cases and different types
of users it's just so much fun okay so
let's check out this one
this selector says if the width is
greater than 540 we want to increase the
padding on our main like layout and if
it's above 800 we're going to increase
it even more
so it's essentially a mobile first type
of strategy
i'll just paste this down here
we can see the spacing on our body
changed right there and here if i come
back to this layout
you can check it out a lot a lot more so
here's our body element
or here here's our main we can see the
border around the side
here if i open up this bug i could even
get that main
with the padding yeah okay i'll hide
this bug there so here's our padding at
mobile and as we grow
you can see we're now at 32 so we're
using another one of our custom
properties and as we grow even more
we've grown to 48.
so those are using rams and vis bug is
just reporting the calculated size here
but it's nice to see the padding um as
it's changing and as you uh resize there
so
kind of cool little use of this bug for
a second
so that we could see our responsive
padding it's like this particular
set of css is like gain more space
around yourself as there's more space in
the viewport because that's
um that's an important decision for this
main to look more
airy and sort of lightweight is to have
it sort of start in a condensed mode
like it's in a mobile phone and then
we're gonna add
more space to it as we grow so let's do
that again
um with our form so here's our form
let's go up to our form element now you
don't have to do this either but i'm
gonna
and i'm gonna here's a custom property
that got made called repeat
i'm gonna add that to the top of the
form element here
and then i'm gonna update our grid
template columns
to have use of our new
custom property or actually here i'll
just grab the custom property
you can copy and paste that whole thing
if you want to um
oh here i did it already i'll just paste
and what we did is we
we replaced autofit with number of
columns
and so or we will be doing that here in
this media query
so by default it's trying to autofit
elements in there
but what we've said is if it's landscape
and the min width is 640 which is
essentially like saying this is a mobile
device
in landscape i specifically want two
columns um even if they're kind of
difficult for you layout engine like i
want them to be that way
and so what we're doing is we're
pivoting a custom property in that one
media query situation
that changes the grid template layout to
be specifically
a two column layout as opposed to sort
of an intelligent autofit
so we're grabbing the reins in this one
use case which is users on a mobile
device going landscape are going to want
to see two columns
let's make sure it's two and that's what
styles are there
i thought that was a good um
user-centric choice to make that
like it kind of gets annoying if you
want to use something in landscape and
it still only has like one in the center
you're like well i have all this space
um and it turned out that that layout
did not autofit
um in landscape and almost all the
devices i tested so i went in and i kind
of made something more specific and said
this is what i want at this point so
anyway here's another one we have
so this is our field set item we're
toggling some items or some values in it
in a media career i'll just pop this
down at the bottom with our other media
queries here
pull this out so we can see it okay so
this one is if we shrink here
we can see that we have like a kind of
smaller space here and as i
grow you see we gained more space here
as we continue growing we gained more
space so this is just sort of this
concept of like a compact versus a
minimal
layout and all i'm doing is toggling
spacing in a media query
you can see in our media query that we
wrote here it's just changing padding
and changing
grid template columns using our
additional custom properties so we're
just kind of growing to an excel growing
to a double xl
to gain more visual space and i think
just on a desktop you need that
air you need that white space to feel
elegant and to feel like it's not
cramped we're on mobile we're sort of
we're accustomed to cramped layouts and
they're not so bad
so anyway again that goes into this
concept of where i'm trying to like
build things kind of condensed by
default and then i expand them
into a more airy and lightweight um
layout and spacing scenario
with media queries as our viewport grows
all right so things to try we've kind of
already tried some of this but if you
want to you can check this out on mobile
check this out on desktop and you know
really what we have here is yeah we have
a
compact and minimal layout that's
responsive
uh and intelligent enough on a mobile
device to sort of make a smart decision
about going
two up into two columns uh okay cool so
i'm gonna move on to our next
section because that's essentially it
for our layout our layout is doing a lot
of intelligent things already
and we've just used css grid to so much
of its power we used a lot of really
advanced
grid layouts there so if some of those
felt a little um
a little far away for your current skill
set don't worry i hope that like using
them and seeing them and having me give
a little bit of a verbal breakdown
helped with those um and let's move on
to color
color is kind of equally intense it has
a lot of complexities that can happen
inside of there but don't worry i'll try
to walk you through today so that by the
end
you at least feel equipped enough to
know why and how you could make
a user adaptive color interface like
something that adjusts to their
preferences
so we're gonna have something that
adjusts to light and dark at the end
something that has color scheme derived
from a brand so i think that's just a
really primary use case is that a
designer
will have decided on a brand color or
you know you'll get a red or a
blue and then you need to build a theme
off of that
and we're going to do that today and
you'll notice that if you look at my
color scheme here
in the preview it is kind of a bluish
tint to it and that is not by accident
if i click on the html
and i come to the brand area here here's
the hue i can change this hue
if i hit shift up and down and you see
it turning green
you see it turning purple and here um
it's using that hue as a base across it
so you look now it's kind of pinkish and
purplish
i'll go back to 200. this is sort of
what i mean is you're pivoting off of a
hue
off of a base brand color and you're
building very
dark colors from it and very light
colors but not necessarily white or
black
you can make really elegant themes if
you try to
reserve white and black for the moments
when you really want a
dark shadow or you really want a white
highlight pop
so those are some color tips for you
here and we're going to build that into
our system today
as we try to avoid using white and black
and opt into
basing everything off of a hue and build
up from there and that's why we get this
nice bluish tinted cool dark theme and
we'll get a very nice well here let's
just see command shift p
let's emulate light see even this
has a little bit of a blue hint to it
they are very light gray
but also very light blue gray and i
think it
most users might not notice uh but they
will know that there's
there's a harmony here and so let's
build that let's build that harmony
i'll show you how i did it and we're
going to build accessible colors
so like if i launch fizzbug here and i
grab the accessibility tool
i can hover over all of these different
colors and know that they are accessible
right great passing passing 12.45
7.27 okay by this bug
and hello colors let's go back to
codepen
and start setting up our brand channels
so i go through a little bit in the
workflow here that we assume
the color is pound zero af so i'm
actually gonna
let's open up dev tools again command
shift c i'm just gonna click something
come over here to the styles hit color
i'm gonna paste that color
and so there's the blue here's the blue
that's our brand but what i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna hold
shift and click that color swatch and
convert it between rgb and hsl and all
that sort of good stuff
because i want these color channels for
free
so that's what that task here is is grab
that hex go into a dev tool find the hsl
color channels because we're going to be
building up color using those channels
specifically in hsl which hsl stands for
hue saturation lightness
and it makes for a really great way to
sort of build custom themes
because of this syntax the way that you
can talk about the color
um and compute on the color starts to
make a lot of sense okay
let's get started then uh on adding some
cool color to this
i'm gonna grab this roots i'm actually
gonna grab the custom properties out of
there and again you don't have to do
that i'm going to come back to the top
and put them here with the rest of the
custom properties
and these are global custom properties
right we have spacing that's being
shared everywhere
and we have colors are being shared
everywhere but we did make one
local custom property earlier right
which was the repeat we said it there in
the form
we could have like like form repeat and
sort of like
made that look like it was stuck into a
component but anyway
i like putting things at the root for
global ones and if you can try to name
your local
custom properties to make sure that they
just don't mix in with the global ones
as you read them anyway whatever
i've put our three color channels here
into the color space
let's see how it's time time looks like
it's uh
getting towards the end i think so
um let's see
so if i've got my color channels there
and i pop down here and i'm just gonna
paste the brand here
so again i'm just creating a custom
property and
setting those different channels we can
see that i use the hue right that i
create right here it's just 200
i divide 100 into so this is going to be
50
saturation and 50 lightness and so
that's going to give us a nice light
desaturated brand color
um and that's what we're going to use in
the dark theme so anyway we'll kind of
build up from there
i'm going to grab these two this so i
like thinking about colors in text
and surface so here's our two text
colors and here's our four
surface colors and if you look at them
they're all based off of the
hue here and then i'm just sort of
setting absolute values i'm saying hey
this is a
kind of saturated and almost white kind
of saturated
and definitely still on the light side
so this is this third channel here is
lightness
and then on my surfaces i'm like okay
they're still in the blue family
they're still slightly saturated and
they're very dark
so as long as you have about fifty
percent and sixty percent difference
between your lightnesses here you can
build accessible color schemes
fairly uh confidently and i would
definitely still say to measure but
that's just a it's a healthy tip to sort
of keep lightness very
stark between these colors and you'll
make sure you have something that's
accessible
okay so i'm gonna grab this next uh
media query here which checks for the
user's preference so here's our first
user preference media query this is
prefers color scheme light
and i'm just going to update the root so
if they do like a um
a light theme i'm going to update that
brand color to be fully saturated so
notice i'm not dividing it by two like i
was previously
we'll grab all of our text here's our
text ones
stick those next to brand and grab this
surface
paste those surfaces in there so
essentially we have light and dark
custom properties ready to be used
they're just not being used anywhere
so let's go use them so the main one
that i always like to use here is on the
body we're going to give the background
of surface one and the text color of
text one right so
text one on surface one is an accessible
color combination
and we want to use them let's paste it
i put that in the body selector there
and we can start to see our page is
coming to life
because i prefer a dark color scheme and
we've built this to handle dark color
schemes
now they're starting to apply so here's
our field set
it's got a border and a background color
where's our field set item
here it is paste that there
our field set item itself i said field
set item before but
this is our field set item excellent so
notice that was a color on the whole
surface there
this color is for each item and there's
our hairline our one pixel starts to
show up there
as the dividing color and here's our
field set item picture
field set item picture gets a color
surface four
now we've used all four of our surfaces
we have this sort of one here around the
icon we have one on the field set item
itself one on the field set group and
then one on the background so we have
four surfaces
two text colors and we're just using
them all cleverly to make this whole
layout
let's get the field set item svg
and field set item focus within so
here's a new selector
and this one right down below it so if
the field set item is getting focused
inside of it
we're going to change the color of the
icon to be the brand color and you can
see that right here did you see it go
blue
see it goes blue so when we have
interaction happening
next to this we get to change his color
and that's focus within so we're saying
hey if this
field set item is getting interaction
some focus
we want to change the svg child that's
next to it and i just i love it you're
going to see some other focuses
within work here here's our small we're
going to set that to custom
color here text to 2 and then for a nice
little kicker here on the root if you
set the color scheme to dark light
watch what happens to the check boxes
and inputs
so here
okay and so here we can see that we got
custom colored check boxes and svg icons
and uh just with one little css property
called color scheme you're
signaling to the browser like it's okay
for you to use those colors here
and i'm getting very uh closed up on
time so you're going to have to
add these last styles yourself that
reduce the motion our goal here is that
we want to look to see if the user has a
preference for reduced motion
and if we do we're going to use color
cross fades or opacity cross fades
instead of some of the
grow and shrink and scale animations
that we would have done otherwise
and that would get you to the end here
where it would be otherwise complete and
responsive and adapting to users from
across the world and
i hope you had a fun time in this
workshop and feel inspired to go make
new interfaces alright see you later
y'all bye
you